no I'm trying to think if there's like a
weird birthday party in my childhood
that just traumatized me and to have
like my own birthday but did you guys
ever have like your own like special
birthday parties as a kid I don't know
if that's like a thing where I really
yeah I'm just trying to think it might
maybe the way I thought about it is that
like I used to have a childhood friend
who had a birthday two days before mine
right and so a lot of birthday parties
were joint books I remember this yeah
yeah so that might maybe be like a
subconscious reason I don't want to be
the center of attention this was in the
age where like you don't get to choose
who's coming to the birthday party yeah
everyone invites everywhere yeah I have
like really weird memories like very
vague though of like kids birthday
parties I I [ __ ] know why it's
because my birthday is like end of May
which is deep during exam season no
matter what before that before that what
about before that yeah before exams like
when you're in like elementary school
because my birthday was in summer so I
never got to spend it anymore yeah
okay so I just got I just got used to
never having a birthday party for a lot
of my like I say teenage years
especially right yeah I didn't have any
you didn't I think I had like really
tiny ones with like the close friends
because when it's in school you can do
like much bigger ones yeah because
because like you I yeah I would go to
like people's birthday party like
everyone would be there and then you
just got used to like oh okay you wanted
to have like a birthday party or
something well sorry revising for exams
or sorry way on holiday or something
like that I'm just trying to think I
literally can't remember a single
birthday party between the age of 10 and
18. I'm trying to remember because I
remember those birthday parties I
remember are the most extravagant and
I've seen yeah I think sausage rolls
they felt like the most extravagant
because I've always like sausage rolls
and crisps and then like some like a
sandwich it's just like dig in did you
ever like did you ever like ever have
like a birthday party where you went to
like a [ __ ] McDonald's or like some
place
[Applause]
like 10 minutes drive from my house and
that was like where I'd say up until
maybe the age of six or seven was like
just just McDonald's playpen party and
then a genius branding of them I think
after that I [ __ ] love McDonald's
from age [ __ ] six yeah and then
literally yeah the other birthday party
that I remember really vividly was uh I
went to I I think it was like seven or
eight it was like right after the
playpen era
um the playpen Arc of my birthdays it
was uh my dad organized a day where we
went to go see the premiere of Finding
Nemo let's hope yeah and so my dad would
make these like invitation cards right
and he would send them off to like the
parents like and being like you have
been invited to the exclusive
Joey's eighth birthday premiere on the
red carpet I'm finding [ __ ] Nemo and
and then literally just after that
there's just a blank period of I don't
remember what my birthday party just
like and then when I was my 18th
birthday party I just got stupidly
wasted I mean actually you know what I
think about it I can barely remember
anything from my childhood
that's a problem
straight up I'm thinking about it now I
can I can scarcely remember I I have
bits and pieces well you remember you're
a member of like all the I think
everything you've talked about
concerning your childhood has all been
on trash days right like just like a lot
of core memories like the beat beating
the French kid yeah that's a very cool
memory yeah I have a bunch of other
scattered memories but I couldn't tell
you what that well that's that's why
trash days is such a weird entity
because most of the time I don't
remember this year and then we're having
like this random ass conversation and
they're just like [ __ ] like I just
get a flashback yeah I remember this now
yeah some birthday parties I just
started getting like flashbacks too and
I was like oh yeah I remember one of the
hypers things because like
um you know I mean I might think about
my parents weren't like broke or
anything but my mama just didn't believe
in spending money on certain things yeah
okay
um I'll put it that way I'm almost gonna
kill me
um so like if we ever went to the cinema
it was like no you're not allowed to get
any of the snacks or anything like that
oh [ __ ] no not at all right just get to
come in and we'll bring maybe a snack or
two from Tesco's or something yeah which
is fair enough I think that's yeah you
know if I want to get that yeah but I
remember when Goblet of Fire came out I
got to go and so on my friends birthday
parties to go and watch it yeah and they
were like hey any of the sweets whatever
you want and I was like what
for real and that was like the hype
issue that was generally the highlight
of like my young like life I just
remember that [ __ ] so much oh man how
awesome that was it was so good are the
other like Ben and Jerry's pick and mix
I wish I never got it not even birthday
but it wasn't me I had to go to one of
the rich kids to get it yeah yeah I
didn't even I didn't even think like I
had a rich kid friend who did that or
anything like I just remember when I was
I was a last minute because someone else
Philadelphia
remember about like Cinemas is like we
used to the the supermarket below the
cinema we used to just buy a shitload of
like candies and chips and stuff like
that just shove them in someone's bag
and you weren't allowed to do it yeah
yeah and like I remember one of like the
[ __ ] managers I guess or whatever was
just like you know someone in like the
40s or 50s whatever was just like what
year it's like pointed to my friend with
the bag and he's like what's in there my
friend's like
jacket like why are you going to jackets
like it's cold in the cinema it's like
all right like he I think he knew but he
was like you're 14 years
why would you I bro I don't wanna I was
like I'm sorry bro I'm not paying 12 for
a [ __ ] box pop like if somebody is
going to the links to bring snacks in
they they were never gonna buy the
popcorn yeah exactly so you've taken
away their snacks or not letting them in
it's not gonna make them buy popcorn
yeah maybe like one out of ten but like
is that really the you really want to
piss everyone off yeah I don't know it's
also like to do with birthdays I don't
think like I never had like that rich
friends but did you have that rich
person in your classroom who wasn't
exactly a friend but for their birthday
party they just invited everyone in
their class yeah yeah yeah oh I didn't
have that did you never have no most of
people invited everyone I wish because
you know they were these type of kids
that would have bouncy castles
this is this is on another [ __ ] level
man yo you go there like they bought
their friendship man you know I'm
jealous I would have milked the [ __ ] out
of them if that was the case I didn't
have that at all because like I think
like bouncy castles and stuff like that
like it was never like a birthday thing
it was always like uh like like a local
like Carnival type of thing where it was
just like like twice a year in this
random open field they'd just be like
yeah let's just see what happens if we
put 20 bouncy castles here you know I
have so many memories scattered of like
being forced to go to like dinners with
people my parents I don't I have no idea
who they are yeah I'm just having to be
in a restaurant for ages because your
parents are drinking yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're like they're talking having a
good time and they're just like [ __ ] I'm
so bored oh I had to do that in Japan
once lately I went like I think I was
like 14 or something and my my dad has
this like age-old friend a Japanese guy
can't speak a word of English right
um for some reason my dad calls him
Brian even though his real name is
Satoshi I don't know where he got that
from but basically I remember but I was
in like an Izakaya and I was like 14
right you can't drink in a [ __ ]
Izakaya 14. yeah so I'm just sitting
there just like kind of just chilling
whatever just you know sipping water and
my dad in his in his drunken stupa he's
like son come over here and I'm like yes
Father what is it and he's like
translate what I'm about to say
and I'm like okay my dad says something
to Brian I'd say it in Japanese and then
Brian goes all right can you translate
this back to him I did that [ __ ] for
seven hours just sitting here like it
was a [ __ ] job to do and I'm like
Father you know I could make a living
and you're making me do this [ __ ] for
free dog I'm expecting the biggest gift
for Christmas this year yo he was
training you man he was training me dude
he was like this will be good for you
son yeah for me there would like my
parents they would always have like I
don't know like my family is big but
what's even bigger is my family's
Network so I would always have like yeah
my mum would always have a friends that
she could visit or well my dad would
have like a friend in Thailand or in
England that they were visiting
obviously when I was a kid I would have
to go with them all right I would go to
the I would go to my parents friend's
house and I just remember like the my
biggest thing was just
it was the one place I didn't want to be
because I was like why are you taking me
away from my [ __ ] games to make me
sit down and drink tea and go to this
house or whatever and just sit here and
do the people I don't know and talk to
people I don't know you know yeah that's
horrible but did I remember do you
remember like how easy it was to
entertain yourself when you were a kid
oh yeah I don't know a lot of memories
of being bored I'm trying to remember
because I all I can remember is being
bored but then I think about it and I
look at Kids now and I'm just like man I
[ __ ] I [ __ ] miss being a kid where
it was like just so easy to like
entertain yourself and I tried to think
back
kids have it easy now yeah yeah because
that because of all the technology they
have access to right like we had what a
Game Boy Advance maybe if you were lucky
if your parents love you enough so
there'd be some things where my parents
wouldn't let me take the Game Boy and
they wanted me to like kind of interact
oh yeah yeah yeah and I would be like
why okay